[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu très content de le voir aventuriers
capitaine des rouges éliminé 38 en à
mahdia très beau gosse j'adore je suis
très content de toi on te kiffe dans
toute la rédaction ça fait plaisir non
mais vraiment on est on est avec toi
fonds honteux qui fait de ouf à bouaké
contentons aventure quand même positif
et tu t'attendais être éliminés ou pas
non pas du tout pour l'instant jamais
être éliminé c'est comme ici les gens
s'attendent jamais dit ça
c'est vraiment nouveau c'est vrai il ya
des similitudes vraiment tu tu attendais
pas du tout pour le coup vraiment pas gt
gt vraiment pas prêt et je me sentais
vraiment bien en confiance dans cette
équipe et pour le coup bah oui quand
j'explique comptait quitter quitter sa
fille bah je sais pas trop il ya une
alliance de filles qui s'est fait à la
dernière minute donc on est en
l'occurrence alexandre à alix et
clémence et elles sont dix bombes à
clémence a dit voilà je demande à mes
lettres que si c'est pour éliminer un
garçon et il y avait claude qui avait
été proposé mais au final les fils sont
dit nono par claude et jeannine alors
justement regarde passer ça c'est ce que
tu en train d'expliquer ça s'est passé
quelque chose la semaine dernière qui a
changé le cours de ton aventure deux
aventurières ont fait une alliance qui
n'a pas joué en ta faveur
regarde
avant le dépouillement je vais rajouter
n'a pas dire un bulletin à votre prénom
conséquences de votre défaite
aujourd'hui dans l'épreuve d'immunité
est ce que quelqu'un souhaite de jouer
ce soir un collier d'immunité
individuelle si c'est possible de nick a
je souhaiterais ses démons amulettes à
une personne ce soir c'est votre droit
je souhaiterais l'a donné à lille
tout de suite le dépouillement sachant
que alix s'il y a des bulletins votre
prénom ils ne seront pas comptabilisés
grâce à la mulette que vient de vous
donner clémence
et sa cartouche en d1 tu as compris le
geste de clémence ou pas
mais pas du tout parce que pour le coup
clémence qui était sur l'île des bannis
elle revient dans le jeu et c'est pas
trop ce qui s'est passé entre eux chez
les rouges et chez les jaunes est prend
un petit peu
la température mais voit que personne ne
la calcule donc quasiment voilà je me
rapprochais un petit peu des filles et
sera peu elle se rapproche en
l'occurrence deux avec sandra et alix et
c'est la loi propose voilà alix écoute
moi je te donnes ton âme il est
seulement si on voit un garçon mais pour
le coup je pensais pas parce que je me
suis voit la clémence à la gagner son
âme il est tout seul s'est battu pour
revenir juste dans le jeu donc de
l'adolescent à mille et alix qui pour le
coup bas n'avaient rien fait pour elle
j'ai pas trop compris après c'est le jeu
c'est comme ça tu l'acceptent pas oui
bon soir oui c'est de fuir
clémence donne son anniv et alix elahian
claude qui vous regarde et vous vous
opiné du chef vous pensez quoi ce moment
là vous dites c'est mort pour moi ou
vous vous en rendez pas 30 ans bon ça
donne en bande de bâtards
là du tout sur le coup quand quand je
vois quand je vois que qui justement qui
me regarde je me dis ah ouais d'accord
donc là je pense que je viens de
comprendre que ça va être compliqué à ce
moment-là je me dis ah ouais ça va être
compliqué alors ensuite donc on l'a dit
il semblerait que tu ne t'attendais pas
du tout à cette alliance entre certaine
grogne actuelle est il ya un instant on
va voir ton élimination ainsi que les
explications des aventuriers et une
excuse tout ça juste après vous êtes à
fond dedans ou en tout cas oui j'adore
plaisir c'est les vacances scolaires
donc on a pu les regarder a exactement
parce que c'est vrai que c'est faisable
mardi soir faire un bon score de 4
millions de ces remontées correctement
baril oui voilà tu nous mets koh lanta
le mardi soir tu veux qu'on arrive le
mercredi matin on a la gueule l'envié
sans rigoler je suis koh-lanta ça dure
jusqu'à 23h45 pour peu qu après tu
fasses un petit pays souhaitait que t'es
pas au lit avant 00h15
[Rires]
c'est vrai mr le coup je m'attendais pas
du tout à ça j'ai essayé de déférence or
de protéger un peu
quelques personnes et au final je me dis
pas moi qui dis à chaque fois le saut
c'est ça paye pas il faut selon moi
social ça paye pas le coût pour les
votes là j'ai pas compris exactement qui
a peu voté contre j'ai voté contre toi
pour protéger alix connaît très bien
avec à étendre leurs complices ou
maville vous d'alexandra j'ai dit non je
peux pas le faire ouais je sais ça c'est
ce que je dis le social ça paye pas et
là pour le coup bas j'aurais peut-être
dû le faire
[Applaudissements]
j'adore ton caractère moi tu me fais
rire j'avance au voyage il faut qu'il
fasse de la télé ne m'a dit je te jure
je te kiffe doit elle est vraiment
vraiment je te dis alors au théâtre /
quand même un petit peu venir bah oui
bah non sur le coup et c'est normal
c'est normal à temps j'aurais été
j'aurais fait comme toi moi j'aurais dit
l'un qu'est ce que vous avez
à la girafe et moundir dans une bourgade
l'ombre à certains vont me dire ouais
j'aurais dit ah ouais ouais pas de
fierté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va aussi revenir sur le
harcèlement qui est candidat subi sur
les réseaux à chaque diffusion le
dimanche 17 octobre 2021 combat a réagi
dans sa story instagram la même tf1 qui
réagit c'est devenu un truc de ouf ça
veut dire que tu paies koh lanta bien
sûr que tu vas faire insulter quoi bien
mais sans rigoler ça veut dire qu'à pas
trouvé une amulette en propre c'est
devenu un truc de fou ça s'est passé
pareil dans le slam quand on trouve pas
fil du
temps mais si malines c'est comme si
dans ces lacs de crever on a super ou
non cette lettre fut alors ça sert à
rien d'être serrée que je suis fou de
slam mais je sais je sais j'adore ce jeu
mais je t'y attends demain 2 avec
médiation envie de le faire sur nani
mais y'a quoi gagner des cd rom
on a de l'eau veille notre plus grand
champion il a gagné 181 millions
d'allemands à lundi